你有沒有想過，你的臉其實也能變成一種資產，可以出租、可以賺錢？
怎麼說？我猜不是去拍廣告那種吧，那是明星才有機會。
不完全是，這裡說的是把你的臉「出租」給 AI。對，就是字面上的意思。中國現在興起一種新的商業模式，讓一般人把自己的臉部肖像權拿去給 AI 生成內容。
出租給 AI？這聽起來有點出乎意料，誰會這麼做？一般人怎麼會有這種需求？我會覺得有點奇怪。
其實就是因為 AI 生成內容的需求太大了。你想像一下，現在很多微短劇，那種超短、手機直式的那種，有超過 95% 都是用 AI 做的。這些短劇市場規模很大。
喔，所以是因為 AI 短劇製作量大，需要大量的「臉」當素材？可是他們不能自己生成嗎？非得用真人的？
這就是重點了。原文有提到，觀眾開始抱怨很多 AI 生成的角色長得都一樣，缺乏辨識度。所以製作方反而需要「有特色」的臉孔，例如老人家的臉，讓劇情更豐富。
等等，這裡我有疑問。既然是「臉部肖像權」，那會不會有風險？像之前不是有網紅的臉被盜用，出現在他們沒同意的 AI 短劇裡嗎？
你說得沒錯，這的確是個大問題。像字節跳動的 AI 短劇平台紅果，就曾被兩個網紅指控盜用臉部。後來字節跳動也下架了超過 85,000 個未經授權使用人臉和聲音的影片。
所以這整個模式的風險，就是肖像權被濫用？那這些平台要怎麼解決？
解決方案就是像 ActID 這樣的公司。他們會幫使用者管理肖像授權協議，還會監測網路，看看有沒有未經授權的使用。如果發現了，還會協助找律師採取法律行動。
這樣聽起來，好像為了解決 AI 內容版權問題，反而催生了一個新的市場。那具體是怎麼收費的？
ActID 透露，從三月上線到現在，他們已經註冊了約 800 個用戶，其中約 300 人同意授權。現在大概有兩個 AI 短劇製作方，透過 ActID 授權了約 10 張臉。
聽起來數字還不是很多。所以實際的費用是？
他們說價格大約是每一集 99 到 500 元人民幣，ActID 會抽取 10% 的佣金。而且有製作方說，授權一張臉比直接請演員來拍還便宜。
99 到 500 元人民幣一集，這單價我覺得不低耶。但這種零工經濟模式，會不會讓大家削價競爭，把價格殺得很低？
這點 ActID 也有想到，像成都一家叫 New Claw 的公司，他們就規定一張臉的最低授權價格是 500 元人民幣，就是為了防止惡性競爭。
我懂了，他們等於是扮演一個中間人，確保供給方和需求方的權益，還維護了市場價格。那如果我是個創業者或中小企業主管，可以從這裡學到什麼？
我覺得最關鍵的是，當新的技術或市場出現時，舊有問題也會跟著浮現。而這些問題，本身就可能是一個新的商業機會。就像 AI 短劇帶來盜用問題，反而讓「臉部肖像授權管理」變成新生意。
你說得有道理，這讓我想起，很多時候我們只看到技術的進步，卻忽略了伴隨而來的灰色地帶。那對一般上班族來說，這種概念能怎麼應用在工作或生活上？
我猜啦，這提醒我們每個人都有一些獨特的「資產」，可能是你的聲音、你的專業知識，甚至是你的某種風格。在數位時代，這些東西以前可能很難量化變現，但現在隨著 AI 工具的進步，或許可以找到新的變現方式。
確實，想想看，如果我的聲音很有特色，是不是也能像這樣出租給 AI 語音生成服務，作為被動收入？這好像也提醒了我們，去重新思考自己的價值是什麼。